Speaker 1: Let's get back to the phones.
And by phones, I mean discord.
David Pakman dot com slash discord is the
place to go.
Let's go next to Seth from San Diego.
Seth, welcome.
What's on your mind?
Speaker 4: Hey, David, I. I just wanted to
ask.
What?
You know, I see a lot of these conservative
ads saying, let's get wokeness out of our
military.
And as someone who currently is serving the
country and it's is my own personal opinion,
I cannot stress that enough.
Of course, is my own personal opinion is not
affiliating with any of the branches that
I'm serving right now.
But when they're saying that there's like
as a person who's in it, I'm like, I don't
see any wokeness around here because everyone
is so unfiltered.
And the only thing I can think of is sexual
harassment seminars or DBA, which means don't
be an, you know, don't be an A-hole.
Speaker 1: I don't know that it's San Diego.
Speaker 4: Anything.
Speaker 1: It's sounding pretty.
Woke to me.
Now you're, of course, completely right.
You're completely right.
And honestly, I think the main Wokeness allegations
came from when Mark Milley was saying, hey,
you know, in the military, we should know
what's in the culture.
And so if critical race theory is something
that is being studied in the culture, we in
the military should at least understand what
it is.
It doesn't mean anything beyond we should
just understand what it is.
And that's when all of the allegations of
woke general and woke military started.
But as you're pointing out, it doesn't really
have any connection to the reality of what's
going on.
Speaker 4: Exactly.
Because, again, like, everyone kind of pokes
fun at each other by like well, like a lot
of the things they said, a lot of race, a
lot of racial stuff was an out, but definitely
some sexual harassment.
And we definitely saw sexual harassment seminars.
Yeah.
Going all the way up to the ranks.
And we do have extremism in the ranks, which
is very popular, but that's not necessarily
a joke.
It's just more like, Hey, this is professional
in the workplace.
We have to be professional in the workplace,
but off the closet you could do whatever you
want.
And that's kind of the same thing is is the
job that I'm reservist, I work two jobs and
there's a girl that was working and she was
very unprofessional, very inappropriate.
And I had to say, hey, what you're saying
is inappropriate.
You can't be doing that in the workplace.
I don't care what you do outside in the workplace.
It's working.
And I'm sorry, but you have to give up a little
bit of your rights when you work.
I mean, now that.
Speaker 1: Right?
I yes.
No, it's not about giving up rights.
It's about your employer can use any legal
means to determine whether they want you working
there.
And so, like saying we don't allow black people
to work here is not illegal means saying we
believe.
Speaker 4: That's kind of what I meant.
Speaker 1: We believe the off the clock social
media statements to be a problem that actually
is legal for employers to consider if they
so choose.
But that's sort of a different, different
discussion.
Let me ask you this.
It is.
Speaker 4: Okay.
Speaker 1: Do you find that most of your fellow
reservists are right wing or left wing or
sort of split?
Speaker 4: I would say maybe around 60% right
wing.
Okay.
There's definitely hardcore Trumpers in it
and that's not hiding it.
Yeah, I would say around like the what I know
of quite a bit of liberal marines, but we
can kind of whisper about it.
We're kind of a little kind of shut our mouths
about it, you know?
It's very it's it seems like it's very conservative,
but there are other people that's kind of
stay out of it or they have their own opinions
or they're not that political.
Speaker 1: Do you think that the left wingers,
at least that, you know, in the military are
a little more cautious about expressing their
views because of a concern as to how it will
be received?
Speaker 4: Yes, very much so.
Probably one of the only people that can is
expressing their views.
And I have the kind of downplay it a little
bit, but I'm not, like, scared about it.
I'm not afraid of expressing my opinions.
If someone asked me politely.
And I'm fine to have a discussion.
Yeah.
But yeah, there's a lot of right wingers,
but I can at least work with them, you know,
I can at least tolerate them.
And we're well, die for each other, literally.
That's what you know.
That's fine.
I'm.
I'm in comm, so it's a little bit of difference.
Yeah, but there's a lot of smart people.
They say all the Trump supporters are stupid.
Not entirely the case.
Their ideas.
Yes, but as a people in general, they're just
people.
They just have the they just have it switched.
That's really mean with what it is.
Speaker 1: All right, Seth from San Diego,
powerful declarations.
Thank you.
Speaker 4: Thank you so much, Dave, and I
appreciate the opportunity.
Speaker 1: All right.
There goes Seth from San Diego